le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
dans une société en crise où la pauvreté
touche 42% de la population manger
correctement et dignement n'est pas
chose facile pour une partie des foyers
réunionnais sur le département certains
réunionnais n'ont pas forcément la
possibilité ni le budget pour nourrir
correctement leur famille une situation
préoccupante et presque intolérable à
notre époque alors quels sont les
alternatives à une telle situation on en
parle maintenant dans le lien social
la crise économique et sociale est plus
que jamais d'actualité chaque année de
plus en plus de familles sont en
difficulté financière économique
sanitaire ou autre des situations
difficiles pour beaucoup de foyers qui
rentrent dans une spirale infernale
la perte d'emploi peut être le début
d'un enchaînement de problème pouvant
aller jusqu'à ne plus manger à sa faim
mais ce n'est pas la seule cause ces
situations sont intolérables pour le
département
malgré des contraintes budgétaires la
collectivité a fait le choix de
maintenir son intervention directe
auprès des associations de proximité
elle a doublé par exemple l'aide
financière à la banque alimentaire des
Mascareignes maillon central du
dispositif d'aide alimentaire cette
initiative permet à beaucoup de
Réunionnais de trouver du soutien et des
solutions dans un contexte
particulièrement délicat et embarrassant
pour bénéficier de l'aide de la Banque
alimentaire il faut emmener tous ses
papiers bien préparés
et là bon on arrive on prépare le colis
et
on s'en va quoi et c'est quand même loin
il faut une voiture quand même parce que
c'est vraiment lourd pour apporter s'il
y a beaucoup quand même dedans il y a de
l'huile
du riz le grain des conseils des pâtes
un petit peu tout ce qu'il nous faut
pour la fin du mois mais par contre pour
moi ça m'arrange comme en ce moment je
travaille plus je suis en retraite bon
le salaire est diminué
avec ça s'il y avait pas ça franchement
m'ont fait du mois c'était vraiment très
très dur pour tout ce qu'on donne c'est
vraiment de la bonne chose ah c'est
vraiment très bon le conseil avec tous
ces efficace grâce aux aides proposées
par les associations subventionnées par
le conseil général beaucoup de
Réunionnais peuvent trouver du soutien
et du réconfort Mireille Sautron et
vice-présidente bénévoles de la BAM
pour elle s'occuper de cette association
et valorisant car elle y trouve un
double intérêt social premièrement aider
les personnes en difficulté deuxièmement
diminuer le gaspillage alimentaire dans
le dispositif d'aide alimentaire là-bas
est chargée de
comment dire de
commander de gérer c'est à dire stocker
et
à approvisionner ses partenaires
localement avec les produits du PEAD
c'est à dire du plan européen au plus
démunis et du Pana c'est-à-dire du
programme national d'aide alimentaire
ça c'est pour les produits européens et
nationaux puis localement nous avons
aussi des ramasses auprès des grandes
surfaces de coopératives agricoles et
industrielle et des industriels et des
collectes annuels quelque chose qui m'a
fait qui a fait que soit venu vers les
banques alimentaires et plutôt qu'une
autre association c'est que ce
cette idée de récupérer et de lutter
contre le gaspillage alimentaire dont on
parle actuellement dans tous les revues
diverses et variées et qui est qui est
scandaleux quoi de destruction que les
grandes surfaces peuvent faire des
coopératives agricoles de produits qui
pourraient aller aux gens si on allait
assez vite si on était assez réactif
donc cette idée de de mutualiser la
Banque alimentaire des plateformes des
associations etc autour de ce projet
pour que le bénéficiaire
bénéficie de ces produits au lieu qu'ils
soient écrasés
ça je trouve cette idée là intéressante
c'est le principe des 79 banques
alimentaires qui existent sur le
territoire national madame Sautron est
bien consciente que pour continuer de
faire exister ce dispositif d'aide aux
personnes en difficulté il faut beaucoup
d'argent sans l'aide du département la
BAM ne pourrait pas continuer d'exister
et donc beaucoup de Réunionnais ne
pourraient pas manger comme il le
faudrait
c'est bien sûr une situation
inconcevable pour le conseil général qui
est lui aussi atteint par la crise et
les contraintes budgétaires mais il
continue quand même d'apporter un
soutien financier aux associations de
proximité et d'aide alimentaire ce
dispositif a été mis en place et plus
accentuée aujourd'hui et notamment par
le conseil général parce que on le voit
la situation sociale de notre de la
Réunion connaît une malheureusement un
vol
dramatique on le sait plus de 50% de
notre population vit en dessous du
soleil de pauvreté il y a une misère
sociale telle que même les travailleurs
sont les travailleurs pauvres
aujourd'hui on le voit les réseaux
d'aide alimentaire sont en train d'en
intervenir encore plus en direction des
publics en difficulté pas uniquement les
publics qui ne travaillent pas ou les
SDF les chômeurs mais également des
travailleurs donc on le voit la
puissance publique et en même temps le
Conseil général est obligé d'accentir
ses efforts en direction des
associations de proximité pour qu'elles
interviennent le plus efficacement
possible en direction de ces familles en
très grande difficulté en 2013
245000 euros ont été distribués aux
associations de proximité dont 120 000 à
la banque alimentaire des mascaren
en 2012 les travailleurs sociaux des
groupements d'unités territoriales ont
prescrit
6190 colis alimentaires en faveur du
public défavorisé au-delà des chiffres
c'est toute une chaîne humaine et
solidaire qui en ressort une chaîne qui
commence avec les élus du département
jusqu'aux consommateurs en passant par
les associations et les bénévoles preuve
que la population réunionnaise continue
d'être solidaire
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais